[Music]
hello there
we are back once again to go over the
latest fortnite update to find those map
changes on the island and link them to
the storyline
and law this season aliens came to town
to take over and their battle with io is
just hotting up
week seven is here so sit your butt down
for eight minutes hopefully
slap code adam arrow in the star to save
this dying series and let's uncover the
hidden story of fortnite chapter two
season seven
let's go
when you boot up for the first time take
a second to look at your lobby screen
it has happened again more parasite eggs
are here
last week there were two this week there
are eight
we are definitely building to something
and like usual those leakers have
figured it out
a live event is coming to the island
fort torrey discovered
a special event countdown file and the
legendary artist big john aka gameshed
made this to help visualize it so keep
an eye out on the growing parasite
numbers and let's hope the next event is
as good as the last one we had
i wonder how galactus is doing these
days
[Music]
oh not so good the first thing you'll
see in the game is a huge rainbow
do you remember the last time we saw one
of these all the way back
in chapter one when we said goodbye to
kevin the cube
darkness was destroyed the multiverse
was exposed
and a rainbow marked the end back in the
game this week this rainbow doesn't look
to be kevin related
but saying that it is over steamy stacks
the resting place of kevin in this
chapter
well this is actually epics nod to pride
month yeah it's a month late but
in their defense they've been on holiday
for a while in the store you can now
pick up these
to scare a homophobe by grabbing a pride
banner and sprays
epic did this for st patrick's day a
year or two back
so it makes sense to assume that this
isn't story related but i think we
should watch it all the same and by the
looks of it our lord and savior graeme
the gnome
appreciates this rainbow gives him
something new to look at
speaking of pride let's check out the
bromance
[Music]
this story has suddenly become pivotal
to the outcome of the entire season
i shizzle you not get your butt down to
camp cod and you'll find bill and ted
one can be found outside training he's
going to town on those targets
using the mightiest weapon of all finger
guns
i helped him out a little but his
accuracy is sublime check it out
but why would he be hitting these
shooting drills now the answer to that
is inside the main building upstairs is
the brother from another mother
at first i just thought he was simply
keeping an eye on the alien craft but
oh no no no i can't say that
but oh no this is huge okay i need to
set the scene to make this
understandable when the season began we
all found a new whiteboard with
mathematical equations upon it
in sloane's office you know the woman
who's in charge of io
right now but this became a deeper
theory when
in the very same room the same equations
were spotted on an image from the past
and not just recent past back when salon
was a child prodigy
these equations must be important and
now let's go back to the bromance
look at that white board again it's the
same equations
i said equations a lot then you should
try it feels good equations
now let's rewatch the bros movements
after watching tv he gets up and studies
the mothership
through a telescope using his phone for
help probably the built-in calculator
he then sits in front of the whiteboard
and thinks
upon writing a few more notes something
happens
he's figured it out he now understands
everything sloane understands
but the real question is has he caught
up with sloane
or surpassed her has he figured out
something new
i guess what i'm asking is are the bros
a bigger part of this story than we
first thought
this would explain why the other brother
is hitting targets outside
these guys have a plan and to add to
this those leakers are back again and
they've told us that this duo are coming
to the store
they will be playable characters we can
all touch the bromance
that's a weird way to put it adam hey
this is a good time to shout out
kodamaru
please please thanks and thanks to those
67 people who used my code last week
[Music]
okay we went deep there so let's do
something dumb instead
it's totally my kind of dumb a few
updates ago we looked at a chair
over by the lake cabin which was slowly
becoming smaller
it was so small last update we thought
it impossible to be reduced anymore
so we challenged those devs can it go
any smaller than this
we challenge you epic games see you next
update
and now look at it this week it's the
most teeny tiny of tiny chairs ever
created
how is this humanly possible this must
be a world record for the smallest chair
in fortnite history
but now that the record is set we need
to challenge epic again
if you are watching our epic overlords
we challenge you to make this tiny chair
even smaller and pink as well that'd be
cool good luck
oh hold up a minute here's a comment
from my last video what if the chair
isn't getting smaller but the island and
everything else
is getting bigger
[Music]
so this week we all expected coral
castle to be reduced to rubble
and like always when we all think we
know what's going to happen nothing
happens
but there is a change at this location
this week
in three places the aliens have ventured
here and left their wares their supplies
this is where the chimera npc can be
located he can be spoken to and even
battled
it may be a jump in logic but this has
to mean this location will change in
future
statistically coral castle is visited
the least in a public game even though
it has some of the most unique sets of
buildings
if this is the end of coral castle there
are two things we need to do
this week first we need to play that
instrument
tune and just in case the coral buddies
are wiped from existence in the next
update
let's hear them sing one last time
nope i love you wobbly blobs
over to holly hedges and the
continuation of the designated alien
home location
the anti-gravity cubes continue to
spread to mimic their home planet
and the trees and other floor and fauna
are taking over drastically
breaking through buildings moving items
mold has set in now the cat food
container has been dragged into the
garage and one of the aliens is living
well here
tuna fish for weeks a quick recap of
last week as i wasn't here
each week the io troops have been slowly
working their way around the island
attempting to understand the alien
invaders and their biomes
by the central divot is now a very
useful io launch pad next to the crater
this thing is a godsend if you're
running for your life away from the
storm
and visiting retail row last week
reintroduced us to this third mysterious
group
the cb radios were active once again and
you could hear the story of the season
from a believer i'm sure you already
know that but just in case you haven't
heard the recordings
i'll link them all in the video from
fortnite assist lastly the anti-gravity
gun we've seen in the opening cinematic
this season
is now in the files actively which means
we'll be able to grab that
in the game in the next week or two i'm
saying this because i really want to get
back into myth chasing and myth busting
again
so if you have anything to test please
throw them my way
i have a list but i need to get my butt
into gear and get it made
before i go something which always comes
up in the comments what about hot watch
well have a look for yourself nothing
has changed we are still waiting for
that trailer to come loose and smash
the sacred hut to pieces also i can
confirm the gnome prison break
has still not happened they are all in
there ready to go i'm sure kevin will
have something planned
but he's watching a rainbow right now
i'm adam you're awesome these guys are
leggings
thanks for using my code over the last
two weeks i promise to up my video
account and get back to regular uploads
thanks for sticking with me it's been a
pleasure i'll see you next time
you